And filmmaker Alexandra Pelosi
joins me now.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate you doing this.
Thank you for having me.
I don't know.
You know,
I like doing these
Well, let me talk about
I think you're doing pretty well
considering considering
the concern is your father.
And here's what you say.
You said your father, Paul
Pelosi, is the breakout
star of my mother's life and of
The Attack on Him
is not in your documentary,
but he plays a giant role.
He plays a big part in the docum
How is he doing?
Well, that's a tough question to
because physically he's healing.
So if you look at him,
he went out to the Kennedy Cente
and my friends were all saying,
this is so great, he's back.
But these are long.
I mean,
traumatic brain injury is not so
that just goes away.
And the threats haven't gone awa
So we're still living with this
every day.
And I don't know how these thing
I mean,
this is a very long term recover
You don't know you're still conc
and there's reason to be concern
I am not surprised.
I mean, how would you feel? You
there's
no you have to
make sense with this in your min
You have to make sense of the fa
that there is an
82 year
old man asleep in his own bed
and gets attacked in his own hom
And I don't care how you vote.
I don't care who you know, what
your political affiliations are.
That's just not right in any
like there's no way.
So making peace with that in you
it's hard to make peace with. Ye
And that's why we're still at it
First of all, we're still under
It's not as if the first just go
This has been something
we've been living with forever.
And it was so
I mean, you could do so coming.
You know, this was so inevitable
When you think about the hundred
of millions of dollars in ads
that the Republicans
spent demonizing my mother,
I used to joke with my father
like she turned her
last name into a curse word
that was 20 years ago.
We made those jokes.
These ads have been going foreve
and ever and ever.
So we were our whole families
had a target on our back for a w
Let's talk about your mom.
I've seen your mom
publicly since it happened,
and she's you know, I asked her
how you do and she's okay.
That's her public face.
How is she doing?
I think this is really traumatiz
And I don't think there's.
You can't have a morning show
answer for this
because it's
so deep in the psyche
of what happens to a person
after something like this.
It's not going to be,
oh, we're doing good.
What do you mean?
Well, I mean,
what are we supposed to say?
It's there's not a good answer f
That's why I'm like such a Scroo
this Christmas.
Like, I can't go to holiday part
because people come up to me, li
how are you?
What am I supposed to say? Yeah.
But 82 year old father was attac
in his bed in the middle of the
How do you answer that?
How do you think I am? Yeah.
And your mom said last month
that Republicans horrible
response to the attack
might have turned off some voter
in the midterm elections.
Do you think that that is true?
I don't know anything about vote
I don't know anything about this
right now.
I'm so
but my faith in humanity
has been destroyed by all this.
So I have no idea if people are
I have no sense.
What I do know
is that how the Republicans resp
this attack was so unforgivable.
The jokes
you saw, the jokes,
the governor of Virginia, the wa
governor of Arizona, Congressman
will making jokes
about an 80 year
old man
getting attacked in his own hear
I don't understand how that's fo
So for me,
the toxic media landscape is so
to try.
And I don't know, I just
I don't know how to talk about t
without going.
So dark.
And it's a morning show
and we're trying to be light and
No, no, no, no.
We want
we want to be real
and also not condemning people w
you know,
like members of the the ex-presi
family who are sending out and s
just awful things
about your father online,
like just not condemning that
at some point.
Like where is the bottom weight
conspiracy theories,
the amount of conspiracy theorie
that were being spread on the In
after this happened It's it's
the social media is destroying
the social fabric of this countr
Do you believe that?
I totally believe
that we've lost all civility.
You don't think that No, I'm ask
Yeah, I look, I limit myself,
especially when it comes to Twit
because I think it's so toxic.
But I want to know what you thin
Well, I'm not social media
because I think it is so toxic.
And I think it really has
destroyed conversations like the
I have friends who actually have
questions that come straight
out of a conspiracy theory playb
But I think,
where do you hear this stuff?
The Internet just spreads
this viral toxic.
It's really dangerous
because it trickles down to
unwell people.
Do you think that contributed
to January six? Absolutely.
You know, I think that January 6
what's interesting,
which is that not everybody
that was there that day is a bad
There are plenty of
good people that showed up to
air their
First Amendment right to protest
But then some of them got carrie
And that's where it gets tricky.
It gets really tricky
when you start to say, well, wha
It's okay to show up and protest
It's okay to get outside the Cap
and wave a flag and say, you don
but then
it's not okay to break the windo
go into the building,
literally poop in the Capitol,
like literally poop in the Capit
I took my teenage boys
through the Capitol
as soon as we
the Capitol was cleared
and we got to go back inside.
We they destroyed the speaker's
Like they broke
everything, like in the kitchen.
And there was just pure
destruction everywhere.
And did you say that you were yo
you were there to film and this
as you were there that day.
You weren't expecting this to ha
You just happened to be there.
Filming this documentary
and you were with your kids, rig
Right.
And then this unfolded.
You never expected in a million
that anything like this
obviously, in hindsight,
you think
you could have seen this coming,
considering how
toxic the
political dialog
has gotten in this country.
If I think about it now, I have
I should have seen it coming
because I've made
a lot of these documentaries.
You know,
this is my 14th HBO documentary,
and I've made films
where you go into real America
and you make friends
and you stay at their house
and you talk to them about polit
And how do you see the world ver
how I saw and I've seen over tim
the landscape has been
just getting more poisoned.
This is a moment from January si
that you filmed.
And here's what your mother
talking about Trump.
This is your mom. Watch
now we
come to
my house and
my mom,
I wouldn't pay to see them
waiting for this.
The trespassing on the Capitol g
are to me.
I'm going to go to jail
and I'm going to be happy.
You take us behind that moment
because we
we don't hear your mom speak tha
but she and she rarely loses her
I don't think she lost her
cool there, but she was very ups
We have to understand,
her father was in Congress
and she's been in Congress for 3
So the Capitol is sacred ground
And so the idea
that this was just becoming
a big freak show
was very offensive to her.
You have to understand how she b
public service is a noble callin
and she believes what they do
is God's work.
She really believes this in her
She's been doing this.
This is her life's work.
So the idea that he was just goi
to make a mockery of this
official proceeding
that was in the Constitution
really offended her.
So then it must be
I want to put words in your mout
infuriating
or just an interesting position
to be in
to see the stances
that they're taking now, many of
especially that Kevin McCarthy g
after that to kiss the ring and
and this whole sort of pretense
about the election being stolen
and not really standing up for i
And you know, sort of straddling
the fence.
That must be an interesting posi
to be in, having
been behind the scenes with came
witnessing them working together
And now the oh, I don't know wha
I think you remember truthiness.
The biggest problem
is trying to make sense of the f
that there have always
been two strong sides in this co
and they did not agree.
But now there's no truth.
There's no there's no we can agr
We can stipulate to the set of f
There's no facts anymore.
And that's the hardest part,
because I have teenage kids
and I have to explain to them, l
there are some facts.
There are things that are true.
These truths right now
it just seems like
everybody's just making stuff up
and you can say whatever you wan
and there's no truth anymore.
You were there
the day that your mother stepped
down, announcing
she was stepping down
from Democratic leadership.
Tell us about think
that was the best day of my adul
Are you serious? Oh, I feel so l
And what about for her, though?
I think she's free.
I think there's a
lot of weight
that comes with these kinds of j
And I think that over time,
it's really become.
I mean,
you just slaying all these drago
It's just at some point, you jus
Don, after my father was attacke
that was it.
We were sitting in the ICU
and we were just saying, we're d
That's it.
We we gave
she gave 35 years to this countr
whether you like her politics or
because you have to like Nancy P
If I watched Fox News,
I would hate Nancy Pelosi, too.
I get it.
You don't have to support her po
You have to at least say, okay,
she spent 35 years doing this.
Her husband,
it looks like Frankenstein over
She's done.
She's she's done.
And what I didn't like
was in the time between the mome
she was done
and the moment she announced,
because all the people think
you have to stay on your country
You keep going, keep fighting.
Let her go.
She served her time.
Were you saying, Mom,
please don't listen to them?
Of course
I get the call from my friend at
That my father's been attacked.
I get on a plane, I go to San Fr
I'm sitting in the ICU with my m
And I said to my mother,
I was very upset
and I said, you know,
when I was 16 years old,
you came to me and you said,
she loves to tell the story.
It's like one of her favorite st
she tells in her speeches.
When I was 16 years old,
my mother came to me and she sai
Mommy has a chance to run for Co
but I won't do without your perm
because I was the youngest of fi
and I was the only one
that was left at home.
So she says
Mommy is a chance to run for Con
but I won't do it
unless I have your permission.
And I said, Mother, get a life r
What teenage girl doesn't
want their mom out of the house?
Go right.
So there we are in the ICU.
And I say to her,
if I had known
35 years later
where this was going to end up,
I never would have given you my
to run in the first place.
Now, my father, coming out of al
he's been through, says to me,
You can't say that.
You have to say
if you came to me today
in this toxic social media envir
you would not give your permissi
but you can't say
the last 25 years of your life.
I'm going to address
that because of this one inciden
So that's all wrestling
with what I'm wrestling with is,
was this all worth it for my fam
What we went through?
Was it worth it?
Now, my parents would say, yes,
my father, after all he's been t
he would say yes.
And my mother, of course,
she would say, I'm proud of my w
because she's proud of the life
that she's lived.
But for the family,
the families are the ones that p
the highest price for this kind